تقف المخرجه المصريه جيهان نجيم وسط ميدان
نيويورك تايمز وهي تفكر بميدان التحرير في
مصر موضوع للفيلم الوثائقي الحائز على عده
جوائز عاشت جهان وسط المتظاهرين وصورت كل
لحظه منذ بدء الانتفاضه تقول جهان ان فكره
الفيلم هي عرض الثوره كما حدثت والاحساس
بالتجربه السيد الرئيس محمد حسني مبارك
بالتخلي عن منصب رئيس
[تصفيق]
الجمهوريه الفيلم الوثائقي يتتبع خطوات
عده مصريين في الميدان من هذا الممثل
الشهير الى هذا العضو في جماعه الاخوان
الى هذا الشاب المصري الذي يدعى احمد
والذي هو الشخصيه الرئيسيه في دراما
الحياه الحقيقيه احكيلك القصه ازاي ابتدت
لما شويه شباب جدعان عشان يحاربوا الظلم
والفساد والفقر ميدان
التحرير اسم الفيلم ذا سكوير اي الميدان
وتدور احداثه في ميدان التحرير بمصر مركز
احداث الثوره المصريه والتي ما تزال
رسالتها منذ ثلاث سنين مهمه وملهمه لما
يسمى بالربيع العربي يقول ليه دي في حرب
في الميدان دي مش صوره لا يظهر الفيلم
الازمه المصريه وصراعها من اجل مستقبل
افضل وينتهي الفيلم الوثائقي كما بدا
بشعور عميق من عدم اليقين ولكن نجيم تامل
المها ان يوثق مرحله هامه في تاريخ مصر
لكي لا ينسى سبب كفاح المصريين منذ
البدايه واعملوا انت عايزينه والثوره جايه
عن اي
ح